so you got the lemons i got the lines
yeah but can you do the windmill huh
up down two over
this is outtakes right here you know
this is how we do it
[Music]
hey i'm drew brees i was quarterback in
new orleans for the last 15 years and
i'm isaac tubes award-winning cajun chef
from new orleans and today we are going
to mix up some great game day drinks and
snacks for your next home game
i know we both got new orleans roots so
i was going to make some barbecue shrimp
i love barbecue shrimp what else do you
like all the new orleans favorites
chalkboard oysters duncan and dewey
gumbo jambalaya shrimp tasso what's your
favorite drink i love margaritas yeah
they go well with anything tell me a
meal that margaritas don't go well with
right we're sitting by the pool relaxing
watching a game hanging out with friends
margarita time i'm making a picture of
the original margarita which has been
around for over 70 years and still made
with three simple ingredients cointreau
tequila and lime beauty and simplicity
right and delicious
so first
one part quantra
[Music]
two parts tequila
one part fresh lime juice and one part
water
we're gonna stir this up to combine it
there you go my friend pour myself one
if i don't mind we're going to garnish
with the lime wheel here cheers salute
that's refreshing it's really good
you ever treat your offensive line to
like special meals during the season
yeah we would always have an offensive
line dinner once a week if you miss the
offensive line dinner you get fined
really yeah and they basically pull that
money up and at the end of the year they
go and have a big party you take care of
those guys they take care of you so
after you won the championship the whole
city came together we had needed it at
that point yeah i know i did too all
right
drink to that
all right i'm gonna throw these on the
grill i'll be right back hi man don't
drink my margarita i'll keep it cold for
you
[Music]
all right shrimp time oh man that looks
delicious yeah spicy too we're gonna
make a spicy margarita go with it okay
awesome i've uh gotten the shaker here
cointreau tequila and lime what else do
i need take two slices of jalapeno all
right and one nice big sprig of cilantro
all right give it a good shake
here we go
oh boy this can be spicy looking good
excellent
all right to you to you
oh
spicy that's got a great kick i'll trade
you one spicy margarita for one barbecue
shrimp skewer there you go
[Laughter]
well that is delicious
the jalapeno with the drink and the
shrimp just a beautiful pairing in it i
agree these are great and ready to go
let's get them inside so everybody else
can try let's go